Welcome, Davide.
Good morning.
Hi, Steve.
Nice to talk to you again.
Yeah, it's...
I'm really looking forward after having
explored some of your material, uh, in the
LingQ Library and then at your channel.
Uh, I have so many
questions I want to ask you.
Uh, but first of all, I should say that I
think the work you do is, is tremendous.
Uh, you cover...
thank you.
...you know, Italian history, Italian
culture, how to learn languages,
specifics of the Italian language.
Uh, it's a wonderful place if I were...
even now to improve my Italian, I would
go to your material and work on it.
So let me ask you, first of all, how did
you get started in this, this, uh, project
of, uh, helping people learn Italian?
Okay.
Yeah.
So I was, I have been a language
learner myself for a long time.
Although in recent times, I haven't
really focused that much on languages
because with the project I've been
focusing on that more, but I was learning
languages inspired by you actually.
And other people, Luca and other great...
oh yeah.
Polyglot content creators and, uh,
and, and I was using these resources
for other languages like the one I'm,
I'm, I'm making for, um, you know,
intermediate learners, even for beginners.
And I thought I should do
something like this for Italian.
That's how many people
get started actually.
They, they want to do something similar
to what they use themselves and and
that's how I started out in, I think it
was 2016 as a podcast hence the name.
I also have a podcast
that's still active now.
It's, it's been a little bit less active
in recent times, but it, it's still
there and I want to go back to publishing
there as well a little bit more often.
And then I opened up uh, the, the YouTube
channel later, uh, where I also have a
lot of content as you've shown, I think.
So so yeah, that's, uh, the short story.
You know, I should, I should mention that
we did a survey recently, uh, on LingQ
what languages people are, are learning.
Italian is surprisingly high.
It is, uh, you know, right now it's, it's,
you know, people talk about Chinese or
Korean or, or other languages like that,
but, uh, obviously Spanish is, is...
I guess maybe because of the influence
of North America or something.
Spanish is, is typically, uh, you
know, right at the top of the list.
French, maybe German and it makes
sense, but Italian is right up there.
Italian is right up there.
Yeah.
Italian doesn't make sense
in, in, in a way, right?
Because it's like, it's
a, it's a smaller country.
It's spoken, I mean it is technically
spoken in Switzerland, San Marino,
you know, and, but it's mostly
spoken in Italy and, um, and
yeah, I mean, it's not a hu...
like there are not that many people
going to Italy to like to work here.
Although I actually, let me take that
back because uh, there are a lot of people
migrating to immigrating to Italy from
other countries, from poor countries for
economic reasons and political reasons.
And so obviously those
people have to learn Italian.
Uh, I just tend not to think about them
that much because they're maybe not
necessarily my, uh, average viewer.
Uh...
So you're average viewer, what,
what is, what is the motivation?
Why, uh, what pushes people
motivates people to learn Italian?
Yeah, it's a mix of things.
Uh, obviously culture, the, the
culture of Italy, the, the great, uh,
the power of attraction of cultural
attraction that, uh, Italy has.
Um, and we can get into that later,
but there's, there are also some...
there's another practical
reasons that many people have,
which is, uh, citizenship.
There was a, a lot of, a lot of people
immigrated from Italy, um, mostly
at the end of the 19th century and
in the 20th century, the first half.
And so there are a lot of, you
know, the Italian diaspora.
Um, there are a lot of Italians all
over the world, or descendants of
Italians, and, and those people can,
uh, get their, uh, Italian citizenship
if they, if they find an ancestor,
an Italian ancestor uh, and they can,
uh, live in Italy or, and in Europe,
in the Schengen Area and and travel.
And so that's a great
advantage uh, for many.
I mean, Italy historically, if you
look at it, I mean for a relatively
small country, has had an outsized
sort of influence on world history,
which is true of other places too.
I mean, I'm becoming increasingly
aware of the influence, for example,
of Persian and Persian history, but
the Italians, starting with Rome, which
in a way was a continuation of Greek
culture to some extent, although the
language of course is quite different.
And in that regard, I thought your, uh,
podcast or YouTube video on Dante was very
interesting from so many points of view.
First of all, I, I have to congratulate
you on how clearly you speak.
Thank you
At, at the right tempo.
You don't speak too slowly, you don't
speak too quickly, you enunciate clearly
the, your, you know, that Italian
intonation, which you talk about in one
of your videos about how, where the,
you know, the emphasis in the sentence,
that syllable of first syllable is
gonna get, you know, lengthened and
a whole bunch of stuff like that.
And of course you do that.
You're a model I, in my opinion, of...
Thank you.
...the Italian language.
Uh, but I thought the, the, um,
uh, podcast or the, the YouTube
video you did about Dante, where
he basically starts to use the the
vulgar, not the vulgar language.
Vulgar in the sense of the
common language instead of Latin.
And, and anyway, go on.
Maybe explain a little bit about
the influence and the importance
of Dante that you touched on in
that, uh, in that YouTube video.
Yeah.
Uh, I mean, as I said, uh, there's
this phrase that, that gets thrown
around a lot of Dante being the,
the father of the Italian language.
Now I have to say not everybody
agrees with that statement.
Uh, even in academia, not
everybody agrees with that.
But still, uh, it's safe to say that
Dante had, was instrumental to Italian
becoming uh, the national language of,
of Italy, even long before Italy was a
unified country, politically speaking.
So, uh, yeah, as I said, Dante was
one of the first, um, writers in in
Italy who was writing in the, the
vernacular language as well as Latin.
He was still using Latin a lot, but it,
it was also experimenting with Italian.
Actually, the first people who
did that were the Sicilians.
Uh, the Sicilian poets
and then came the Tuscans.
But that leads me to a quest..
That leads me to a question, because
you say that in, in your video, uh,
and you say that Dante unified Italy
through the power of his language,
rather than, you know, by the sword.
Okay.
Yeah.
So the question is then
how did he do that?
How did, why is it like it
wasn't through force of arms?
Why did Tuscan, the Tuscan language
as developed by Dante rather than the
Sicilian or or, uh, I don't know what
other possible, you know, vernaculars.
How did that happen that the
Tuscan language dominated?
Well, I guess because the Tuscan
literature was so influential everywhere
in Italy, it was among the first,
as I said, maybe it wasn't the, the,
the first uh, but it was among the
first examples of, of literature, uh,
literatures in, uh, vulgar languages
in Italy, in a vulgar language.
And it was the most influential,
uh, because of how, just think of
the fact that we had three authors
like Dante, Petrarca and Boccaccio.
All, you know, being born very
close to each other in the span
of, I think it was less than a
hundred years, or even less maybe.
So, uh, it was, maybe it was,
there was even a little bit of a...
like, it was even a coincidence in a way.
But, uh, a lot of great writers
were born in, in Tuscany, and, and
that led to Tuscan and Florentine
becoming the, the most influential
literary, literary language in Italy.
And, uh, not the only one, but you
know, uh, the one that mostly I, I,
by the 16th century, uh, became the
accepted, you know, uh, literary and,
um, sort of the Lingua Franca of, of the
elites in, in cultural elites in Italy.
Of course one of the one attractions
of Italy is, is the strength of all the
sort of regional historical background.
Napoli or, or, uh, I don't know,
Milano and, and Venezia, which was
off by itself and, and, uh, various
types of foreign domination at
different types of, of Italy's history.
So there's a lot of variety there.
Uh, and of course beautiful
cities and so forth.
Another thing you do in your channel,
which I think is great, is you
teach people how to improve their...
and maybe you could summarize the,
the video you did on the stress and
the, the syllable stress and the
stress, the intonation in a sentence.
I thought that was very interesting.
You remember, la casa?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The, the, the one with the tips
on how to sound more Italian.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, that's an interesting one.
So, um, uh, what did I talk about
in the, I talked about la casa.
Yeah.
For instance, you mentioned, right.
So.
Like in Spanish, a word like casa has a
very short, stressed first "ah", casa.
Well, an Italian, and this makes
Italian sound the way it does.
We tend to make that "ah" make
that stressed vowel longer.
So it's casa...
Spanish...
anytime you would say...
so you elongate those vowels more and
that's, it makes you sound more italian.
But, but you made the point
that that depending...
like....
so depending on the stress in...
like wherever the stress is,
that, that's where that happens.
So it, it's not automatic that
every time you see casa, it's gonna,
the stress is gonna be the same.
Yeah, no,
no, exactly.
So it's usually the last word in
a sentence, but it also depends
on where the, the emphasis is...
um, but if you say...
instead of...
so my friend, so in that case that's
a little bit technical, but yeah,
it's, uh, uh, that's interesting.
So, so how does one, how
does one acquire that?
Does one acquire that by just
doing a lot of listening and
being attentive to the language?
Or is it necessary to have
that pointed out or, I guess
it depends on the individual.
Yeah.
I think it depends, and I think it's,
it's a mix of the, of both actually.
Um, you, of course, you have to do
a lot of listening as we, as you, as
you, you know, teach on your channel.
But I think it, it, it helps to
have people point things out that
you might not necessarily notice.
And, uh, yeah, I don't know.
What do you think?
Do you think...
uh, I think, well, you know, I always
quote this, uh, lady who ran the San
Diego State University Language Department
who said, there's only three things
that matter in language learning: uh,
the attitude of the learner, the time
you spend with the language, so not
reading a grammar book in your own
language, but actually with the language,
reading, speaking, listening, whatever.
And the third thing is
the ability to notice.
And I think to some extent the
ability to notice develops if
you put enough time into it.
If you have a, an attitude
that you want to notice, but
some people just don't notice.
The question is, even those people
who don't notice, even if you
point it out, it doesn't mean
they're gonna be able to do it.
So it it's kind of a mixture.
It's, it's, sometimes it helps,
I, I wouldn't say it doesn't help.
It's like in Russian, the
unaccentuated "o" becomes an "ah",
some people don't notice that.
You point it out, it doesn't
mean they're gonna do it.
So I It's a mixture of both.
Um, yeah.
Another area where I thought we, it was
interesting you showed those circles of...
in other words this whole issue
of how many words do you need?
How do you activate your vocabulary?
And you had one person on there who was
very much into, you know, every time
you learn a word, write it out, use
it, which I'm not a big fan of because
it's, it's gonna limit your vocabulary.
So there's always this issue of how
much focus on this bits and pieces,
the details versus how much of the
language are you gonna bring into you.
Uh, and I think you have
to strike a balance.
Uh, and you pointed out too that you
have this sort of larger circle of words
that you know, in a very small number
of words that you're comfortable using.
Uh, at some point you have to expand
that, and you do that by speaking more,
and you shouldn't be afraid of speaking.
But at the same time, if you have
a very small, larger circle, you'll
never have much comprehension.
You'll never have, you know, words
that you can eventually use to
increase your active vocabulary.
So there's this constant push and pull
between how much input and how much you
actually have to use what you've learned.
Where do you, where do
you see all of this?
I mean, um, I'm a massive fan of,
uh, I'm, I'm a huge fan of massive
input, uh and I've been, you know,
influenced by, by you on this.
And I think you, you absolutely
need to immerse yourself as much
as possible in the language.
But, you know, there are a lot of people
who just do that and then they, they don't
speak very much and they don't speak well.
Even, and if they, you know, if they don't
have an, if they understand everything
perfectly, so uh, you really have to
speak a lot and, and, and write if you
want to do those two things well, it's,
it's not gonna be automatic, although,
of course, listening and, and reading
is going to help, but it's, there's not
a, an automatic influence on how you
speak and how you produce the language.
Um, I think.
You eventually have to speak.
There's no question and
eventually have to speak a lot.
Uh, and, and I would say that, um,
yeah, as someone who wants to learn to
speak and I think Italian, any language,
it's fun to speak the language, you
know, it's fun to, you know, imitate
the intonation of the native speaker
as, as close as you can get to it.
And, um, there's a almost like that's
the game, that's what's fun to do.
So I agree with you that some
people are reluctant to do that.
It's a little more difficult.
You gotta set up a, a meeting or online
or face-to-face, so it's more difficult.
It's easy just to turn on
your MP3 player and listen.
Yeah.
It's almost too easy to
consume content these days.
Too easy yeah.
Uh, it's so easy...
I agree.
Like it's, it's, uh, it's
what you do by default.
But yeah, you, you, you have to speak.
And, and I, right.
And, and I think the joy of expanding
your vocabulary is that there's
so much good material in Italian.
Oh, and, and you also had one, uh, a video
and you talked about the importance of
reading, and I totally agree with that.
I mean, reading is, is
absolutely essential.
That's where you expand that vocabulary
base, the, the, the passive, the
potential words that eventually
might be added to your active mix.
Um, but there's so much good
material in Italian available.
When you go to Italy, um,
how widespread is English?
So if you're an, a person that
would like to visit, to visit
Rome or Florence or whatever.
Um, or even, uh, I don't
know, Bari or Sicily.
I mean, there's so many wonderful
places to visit in Italy.
How widespread is is English?
To what extent can you
survive with just English?
To what extent is your experience
in Italy gonna be richer by
being able to speak Italian?
I think it's going to be a lot
richer and obviously like  knowledge
of English really depends
on the city, I believe also.
I don't know if I'm, if I'm the right
person to ask because I'm not going
to speak English to other Italians,
but I think it really depends.
If you go to Florence or Rome
or Milan, it might be easier to,
to, to get by speaking English.
Uh, but if you go to even Bari or
other, other places, smaller cities,
smaller towns, um, it's going to be near
impossible to, to, uh, to use English.
Especially if you go to, I
don't know, small borghi.
We have this, these borghi uh, these
small, very small towns or villages, I
guess you could call them villages in
English, which are beautiful in, in Italy.
I think they're worth the visit.
And if you want to communicate
there, you're not going to be
finding English very useful.
So, uh, I think it's definitely making the
experience a lot richer and in general.
I would say we're not
that good in English.
Uh, you know, we're probably a
little bit better than the, than
the Spanish, than Spanish people.
And, uh, if I had to say, or at
least we try harder, but still,
we're probably in the, in the bottom
countries when it comes to English
proficiency in the European Union.
So still not that good.
Behind the, behind the Portuguese
who aren't too bad in English?
No, the Portuguese are, are incredible.
Um, yeah it's a matter of, we, we
haven't had much English speaking
films and movies and all that and um
we have everything dubbed in Italian.
And so I think that played a, a role.
And, you know, one of the big attractions
of Italy is food and particularly in
a smaller town, but I can remember
being in, um, I can't remember whether
it was Bologna or, or where I was.
But, or Parma and in a lovely restaurant
and, uh, without Italian, you know, you
couldn't order and you couldn't engage
the, the mama who was running the place
and sort of chit chat back and forth.
And even in the smaller towns,
that's gonna be even more the case.
So for anyone wanting to explore
Italy and explore the food and
explore the countryside, uh, having
Italian is, is such a big advantage.
And, um, yeah, and I think...
Go ahead.
Sorry.
...a lot more authentic and
genuine and fun, so, yeah.
I, I totally agree.
And I, I hardly recommend your channel.
Uh, as I say, because of how clearly
you speak, how pleasant it is to
listen to your Italian and the range
of content you have from history
to the language itself to how to
learn and lots of different things.
So, uh...
And I also have the podcast, if
I can promote my, my own podcast.
Go ahead.
Please.
I have a lot of, lot of content on, on the
podcast as well, um, uh, interviews and...
You provide transcriptions,
don't you, for your podcast?
Yeah, yeah, I do.
So anyone who listens to your podcast
or your videos, which has subtitles in
Italian, both of those can be imported
into LingQ, uh, for your own use.
We, we have one item in there that,
that is shared in our library, but
nothing prevents our members from,
uh, subscribing to your podcast or
to your YouTube channel, and then
importing those into LingQ as lessons.
And, uh, I can't think of a better
way, uh, to work on Italian.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, I've used LingQ
a lot myself in the past.
I've learned Russian with LingQ.
Um and I've used it for, for
French, I think I use it for French.
Yes.
It's a great platform.
I always recommend it to people.
Um, and, uh, yeah, I mean, if, if, if, if
you like this immersion based learning,
I think, uh, you're gonna love it.
It's a wonderful world we live in
where there's so much content available
now in, in Italian or in Russian or
in French or, or other languages.
And different ways of
accessing this content.
So, uh, language learners
today are very fortunate.
So with that, I mean,
we can go on forever.
I want to get back to your
channel and do some more Italian.
Uh, but thank you for dropping
by and, uh, I will leave links
obviously in the description box...
thank you
...to your, uh, to your, uh, podcast
and to your, uh, YouTube channel.
Great.
And people who enjoyed , how do you say?
How do you say...
...
um, and, uh, people who enjoy
these videos, please, uh,
uh, uh, you know, subscribe.
Click on the bell for notification.
And if you follow me on a
podcast, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
So thank you very much Davide there.
Thank you very much, Steve.
Bye-bye.
It was a pleasure.
Bye.